what the [ __ ] is going on i like to
party
jesus honey this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends
yep
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine stallone you guys if
you're watching this right now you're
probably wondering
why sophia and i are sitting on the same
side of the table
next to each other very strange i don't
know how i feel about it i don't like it
we're blocking our camera angles
but the reason we're doing it is just a
spectacular reason
back by popular demand ladies and
gentlemen
the listeners of the unwaxed podcast we
have heard
we listened we brought back our favorite
guest of all time
drum roll please
jennifer flame and still our mama mom
thank you so much for coming back on the
podcast i don't think you realize
the overwhelming amount of responses oh
from your last episode thank you
no seriously well you have great
listeners
she's like the listeners know what's
best
they're smart people they are they're
really smart so why don't you give them
just a little update on your life what's
been happening how are you feeling
oh my gosh there's so much going on
right now because i
am redoing our house in palm beach i'm
decorating and
i'm getting ready for scarlett to go
away to college so i'm really going to
be an empty nester
big life changer you know i read
somewhere that
the three things that stress people out
the most in life one of them being is
moving yes
and your kids going to college so what
is your level of stress once
it's like out of like a strong nine
straight strong
hard nine and it is a lot of stress it's
a stress it's emotional stress physical
stress mental stress
and your dad and i are going to be home
alone
so that's going to be that's going to be
quiet for the first time in over 20. you
do have five
years so well yeah we're just going to
probably keep having dogs
well i've never thought of it this way
but now that you're saying it out loud
you and dad haven't been alone really
for 25 years we've always
the kids have always just been part of
your relationship right
and that's a huge thing i mean it's a
big distraction
right so it's almost like you have to
get to know each other again
which is so so strange are you guys
going to go on date nights what's
happening
you know we could do a date night i
don't know i don't know um
usually i make you guys go on all my
date nights like sometimes it's gonna be
very odd to have just him alone i know
something i remember sometimes dad going
i really want to take jennifer out i'm
like alright yeah you should die and
then mom goes okay girls i made a
reputation
but he loves us he loves the women so i
thought you know the first time we had
you on the show
everyone got to really know you on a
personal level got to know your history
your upbringing
really goofy well that's exactly what we
want to do today
because i feel like the first one was
heavy this one let's just be
silly girl talk like yes let's just our
other side
we decided to bring her in to our normal
routine which is where we start with the
weekly update
on just crazy things that happen
throughout the week so you know bring in
some commentary if you've had anything
that happened this past week that's been
kind of
some notable to share go ahead um okay i
got
kicked off the board of my neighborhood
they voted you did i loved the park you
built what happened
i know i was really a good board member
but they saw that my house was up for
sale
and i think they just said you know you
might be moving
and you can't be part of the board
anymore but it was kind of sad because i
built a really good relationship with
the other board members
and i really liked them so it was a fun
monthly meeting and for years
so so i can't be in charge and i can't
suck
be in charge of the park the funniest
part is you're probably one of the most
proactive
board members on there going like we got
to fix the park we've got to fix the
trees the bushes
and now we've got a plant do we gotta
know the lawn and we have to make sure
everything looks pretty in the
neighborhood so yeah
i love being a part of that port so what
went wrong
yeah well i just think they wanted some
new blood also that
a few of us have our homes for sale one
of our other board members
um she left she moved out so they just
kind of said you know it was a cardboard
clip i have a question
by the way and it's all volunteer by the
way
and i work more pretty much for the
board than i did at my own how did they
like decide that you were cut out did
they have a private meeting between
themselves
they had a vote and so the neighbors
voted did you know this was happening
yeah but the horrible thing is like
i voted for everyone a lot of people
that were part of the board
they voted five you can put your name
down five times and that would have
counted as five
but i included all the other board
members so
i only voted for myself once but then i
and i liked everybody else i put their
name
down and the girls that won kind of
heavily
you know went out to every neighbor all
right
and took you off yeah but it's okay
you know mom's hold on this is like
funny the mean girls that keeps me girls
so far it is true it's that's so sad and
i feel like you know
how you acted in this situation just by
voting for everyone
is how you were in high school just like
a little goody two she's always doing
the right thing i always wanted you know
playing fair actually it actually broke
my heart because two of the other board
members got
um booted as well oh and they've been on
the board for almost 20 years so for me
it was okay but i felt so bad for them
because
they've worked so hard and so i was
almost in tears
when i heard they got booted oh the
drama the drama of the the god
mama is something i wish to have right
now
our drama is just ridiculous but mom's
just like but it was sad you know i'm
sad for you
you were really excited about it but i
think it's also a good thing because
it does break away from this
life here you've built in l.a yeah so
and i do know i have to pass the
baton along and right and it's okay like
trust me i'll survive
i want to talk about something that you
decided to put on the tv for us the
other night
i know i'm so late to this game but
netflix put out a movie documentary
called
my octopus teacher let me just paint it
aka
my girlfriend my girlfriend octopus and
i get that this was
very popular months ago but i'm very
behind with all the trends so we watched
it the other night yes
and it was a beautiful story if anyone
doesn't know what it's about it's about
a diver in south africa who visits this
little female octopus every single day
for an entire year
and what was sort of meant to be a
beautiful story between
man and octopus was destroyed by
jennifer's commentary and my commentary
the entire time
for example um well the more the
documentary
sort of progresses yeah played out the
creepier the relationship
got between the guy and the octopus and
now you're thinking
okay well how creepy could it be it's
just an octopus and a man
but you know i thought it got a little
bit how would you describe it
a little bit um infatuation with this
thing
into it to a almost borderline
girlfriend
boyfriend relationship he called it his
relationship
right really he he described it as the
pure magnificence of her
and all i could do all of the time was
just think of her and that's what he was
saying about this octopus i want to live
with her every single day this sounds
like the movie
her with the whole iphone like
relationship with like something i mean
it was absolutely stunning to see this
all unfold
i mean this world that we would never
you would never think an octopus would
become attached
to a human and do you remember what you
said to me
oh no do you remember me i don't
remember
i say a lot of stuff as this is going on
and i'm like okay when is this guy i'm
sorry gonna have sex with this octopus
it's gonna happen
you said sistine if this guy
can find a relationship yes with an
octopus you can find a man
that's what you said to me and i said
you're right
you're 100 right because we sit home
every night together sistine
and sophia seems to have you know a few
friendships she goes out with
girlfriends but like you're always going
out and it's always sort of sistine and
i
left alone on the couch together eating
popcorn and you know drinking and
watching creepy documentaries exactly so
i thought wow this guy actually found a
relationship for a year
why can't my daughter sistine find one
and i didn't mean it to sound like that
but it did come out like that and maybe
there is some truth to it
well you know what there's someone for
everyone so if a guy wants to date an
octopus fine but maybe i should stop
looking for man and start looking for
perhaps a car or a tree kangaroo
kangaroo i don't want you under the
water so maybe
something above water i agree i agree
speaking of relationships
sophia are you good with your mic right
now i'm just trying to not block you
right now it's okay you can block me
okay i'll do it like right there is that
better yeah yeah i'll
go ahead so speaking of relationships
you came home freaking out the other
night
oh yeah can i i don't know if you
believe in this stuff mom
but so you know how megan fox and
machine gun kelly are together and
everyone's like oh they're
twin flames do you know what twin flame
means at all um
it means they're horoscopes you told me
about this yeah horoscopes
uh are exactly in line i'm sorry you
didn't
yeah you did tell me i know but i'm okay
good so if you don't know what a twin
flame means it just means your sun your
moon
and you're rising all the same and i
don't care if you don't believe in it
it's real
go check yours because i guarantee it's
going to line up exactly with who you
are
but i go to my girlfriend's house and
she's having this little get together
and i run into one of my girlfriends
that i met in college
and we for one show up looking exactly
the same
white shoes same jacket same shirt
same hairstyle everything same height
and we realize
we have the exact same zodiac and so
she's my twin flame
and i realized while we were in an hour
conversation
everything we said everything we did was
on point okay but do you believe in all
that
i just think you're in la and everybody
wears
everybody wears crop tops and white
pants i agree everyone wears a slick
back bond with a lot of the jacket
says the girl that likes when i read her
horoscopes no no i do believe in it a
little bit but i i also think that
we do have a dress code in l.a just like
if you go to florida everybody's in a
summer dress and here everybody's in a
pair of jeans
but i have never met someone that had
exactly the same lineup as i did
and it was kind of freaky because we did
look exactly the same like also brown
hair brown eyes yeah it's true
it was weird i'm a leo and i i'm very
attracted to female
leos not the male leos but the females i
don't like amelio
i like female leaders yeah and i really
get along i always go out with millions
but always just doesn't always crash and
burns
but i thought it was pretty funny just
because we always talk about like we
want to find a boyfriend i'm like do i
just like go out with her now
she's my twin flame is this my machine
gun kelly
this is it no um no
just because i know you she's not going
so well yeah
you uh yeah she's not like five football
players
not exactly yeah exactly exactly you
know sister and i
i i don't know if you've heard us say
this in the kitchen a lot but
i think we're manifesting something
that's probably going to end up being
probably the worst for us
in we manifest a lot of things you got
to be more specific i have to call
sistine out so
the last episode right it was all about
us having a toxic girl summer
and we were saying that we want drama
well i don't know if you've heard us say
this in the kitchen
i've heard you guys i don't know if you
feel good about it i mean i'm like what
does that mean does that mean like
getting drunk every night being stupid i
mean what is toxic girl toxic to me is
like doing drugs
no no your body isn't toxic you're just
doing
toxic activities for your brain like for
emotionally
toxic yes emotionally toxic so we're not
going out with bad boys
yes maybe going back and forth how is
that going to help you in
any way but that's why it's toxic i have
a question mom
she hates it i hate toxic let me ask you
a question i mean you're not going to
fly with me
how about this join us
have you ever what is this
yeah i don't know this is toxic she's
doing dog ears
have you ever when you were in high
school for example go back to your
ex-boyfriend
uh never
okay never because i i met your father
when i was
almost 20 and i'd only had been broken
up with my ex-boyfriend for two weeks so
that wouldn't have
we can't actually explain toxic girl
summer who's never she's never had
i've never had it i thought you would
probably like this
and i'm gonna i'm gonna prove a point
you're in love with all of our
ex-boyfriends
yes even more excited even more so after
we
i wish i could invite them over all the
time i really do i think they are the
nicest guys ever and i love them that's
a toxic mom summer yeah i know
she's still texting she's happy birthday
by the way i'm still upset you guys bro
she's lit by the way can i just say this
to any of our exes listening
um jennifer loved loved you guys so much
like almost like a son exactly and so
when we would ever
talk about you know maybe we should end
the relationship with them
she would beg beg us now i was so upset
so upset so we ended up dragging it out
for another three to six months just
because
you didn't want us to i'll tell you
mom's idea was having all of our
ex-boyfriends in the room doing a puzzle
together well that's what we did
yeah that's what she used to do with all
of them and then we stayed up all night
two three in the morning you know what
no puzzles
now that i'm thinking about it every
single time an ex has reached out to me
you can attest to this too the first
thing they ask is how's your mom
every single time and now i'm thinking
i love them see is that the secret to
having men like you it's just
act very maternal maybe that's what we
should be doing i think you should
yeah i think don't be like the boss i
mean guys you are the boss
i'm the boss but i grew into the boss
yeah that's true
i was very very maternal and quiet and
really sweet yeah when i met your dad
and then
how are you guys you guys are very
controlling in a relationship and i
think
i think you guys are a little bit of the
boss but i think that this should be
like
you should give up a little bit of boss
because
where you want to travel what you're
going to eat that night what restaurants
you're going to go to
what else do you think that's sophia
what you're going to do during the day
it's controlling i think i just know
what i like sophia is way more
controlling oh you're a bit controlling
in what way i don't care about that
emotionally emotionally
um when you allow them in when you let
them out
you are you are just let's see
she emotionally i'm finally i'll tell
them what to do i would
i'm like if they text you you text them
right back i don't like this five-minute
or i have to wait five years or five
years
totally agree i think that i hate games
i hate games too sophia tells me
if you're not playing the game you're
losing the game and i say why do we have
to
no games no games at all no games there
if this is if
you're not in the game you're losing the
game and if you never acknowledge the
game
you're already losing the game play the
game in vegas you don't play it in your
real love life there is a game
play blackjack play blackness players
you cannot you cannot play you know like
play craps on the toilet perhaps on a
toilet wraps
craps like [ __ ] no toilet one for us
what are you talking about craps on a
toilet there's the craps the game craps
why of all the games crafts auditorium
because that's the funny game
okay i don't understand it let's say
let's say play monopoly
by the way so back to speaking about x's
the reason why i brought up
toxic girl summer and i think we're
manifesting is because we've been saying
it so frequently every single day
that sistine in one day
two days ago i i don't want it genuinely
spoiler and then when i say x's you guys
i also mean
people that she dated a little bit or
like long-term release
of our episode on twitter this is what
happened
i got seven messages from ghost of
boyfriend's past
yeah what now let me tell you it wasn't
me
which one she's smiling
see i um was actually thrilled about it
because that means they still miss me oh
but i didn't answer them
okay mom i know your daughters are a
little bit toxic a little bit crazy but
we're really not we're just trying to
you know
keep it fun you're trying to live your
best life right now but you know
you're trying to keep it fun but
sometimes it's a lot more fun when
you're
doing something with someone you
actually care about i
can going solo flying solo is not that
much by the way
i am so ready for it because you've been
flying solo both of you for a long time
oh how long mom how long well
according to my calculations mom's like
since the last time you spoke
of my choice okay it was uh january
she's like
i'm bored of you guys not bringing home
i'm really
lonely at the house i need someone to
talk to and i love
yeah we need some male energy yeah we
need some more mail-in it is but you
know i actually totally agree with that
statement
i think being single is totally
overrated if it's a good relationship
it's really fun getting to experience
something with someone
all day like going to i just like like
calling somebody in the morning at night
checking in with them making sure
they're okay just all those fun things
it's like important to have your time to
be alone if you need to
like figure out you guys have been alone
for a long time okay so we can just like
say louder you guys have been alone
for a long time
rip headphone users i know honestly no i
was watching this video the other day
and it was this guy saying
everyone wants a single girl summer
everyone wants to be single for the
summer and he goes but you missed those
three text messages in a row and you
missed those good night attacks and you
missed facetime until
the morning summer you've been you've
been gone you know without somebody fall
winter spring too
so it's not like you know how much how
many
times are you gonna say oh she really is
making those seem like we're eight you
guys have been single for three seasons
all of the seasons but it is kind of
honestly it is surprising how long we've
been single and not found because i feel
like
everyone else that's gone out of a room
all you guys are single even scarlett
which is she's going to college i know
she's
scarlet's a hard one to lock down for a
relationship i feel like
yeah she she was locked down for a while
she was like no i mean now she's yeah
she's harder now because she's going to
college but i it is weird that a lot of
my girlfriends that
used to break up with a guy are all back
in new relationships
yeah why is it so hard for us well i'll
tell you how
the best way to get in a relationship
right now is not go on the dating apps
it's to get introduced through mutual
friends yeah now
we tried that this might be a crazy idea
but mom this isn't for you sofia how do
you feel
if i brought in some maybe some blind
dates on the show
and had sophia go on three blind dates
oh well i agree
with that because i would definitely be
able to pick the best ones there you go
no no no i'll find them for sure i think
that's a terrific idea because i would
definitely be able to pinpoint the guy
that's going to stay home
do puzzles oh you're going to mind with
me you are going to be here but you
could
buy all these you're calling the studio
oh i'm going to be in the background i'm
going to have like cards i love it
yes i don't know i love it maybe let's
transition we asked all of our listeners
uh to submit their questions for you and
so answer however you like
okay so the first person wrote in mama
jennifer
how do i know he's the one
you know in your gut and your soul
there's
nobody can tell you he's the one except
you know you just physically mentally
every time you see him your heart
flutters
he puts a smile on your face how did you
know dad was the one
i just knew but he was just that perfect
man to me maybe he's not perfect for
everybody for me though every time he
came around
i always always got excited i was always
happy to see him
and he was just a lot of fun and made me
laugh
yeah you guys have a lot of fun we laugh
a lot and i love being super silly and
he's
super silly so it was like we got along
really well i just think you know you
know you know
there's you know sometimes you walk past
a person you're going
gosh i wish i could get to know them
sometimes just like that
that's just feeling do you think it's an
instant feeling do you think it's
something that also has to be nurtured
too
because i feel i totally get the same
way i've met guys where i'm like
instantly the first time you love at
first sight you have that
connection but then i've also met guys
where it had to take
three times for me to actually notice
and go oh wait we really do have a
connection well i feel like you have to
make sure your head is in the right spot
when you meet them
you have to can't be getting out of a
relationship or you know things like
that
i really think that you have to worry
about i think there's a certain window
that's when you should start dating
after you've gotten out of the lost
relationship
kind of i think it should be i mean
sometimes so it's not
like say it's always true but i really
do think if like you're in a
relationship for a couple years you've
got to give it at least six
months to a year before you jump into it
i never understand why people the next
month will get i don't well i just
i feel like you know sometimes people
don't like to be alone and it works for
them
but i really think you got to find
yourself again and really find
what why this other relationship didn't
work out yeah and then
see what you want from the next one
that's true and i always forget
that you need that time to be in the
best place for yourself mentally to find
that best person for you
you hate when people tell me that it's
true i mean i feel like at this point
you are
pretty good i don't know how much more
mentally ready i think you're ready
i think everything is ready head to toe
ready sister can i hear that guys i'm
ready
she's ready she's ready rock and roll
rocking and rolling here we go
um okay the next question is what are
your thoughts on sophia wanting babies
now
see last episode sophia was talking
about how intense her baby fever was
yes and you know because she came home
and told you about it so she told me
about it for about three or four days so
i do know i just think
uh babies are not like puppies you can't
just say okay
here's someone else take care of you it
is 24 7. you really have
i i really think now that you give up
your life but you kind of do give up
your life because you're
now you've brought this other person
into the world and you have to spend
every waking moment with them um i
thought you'd be happy about this no i
am happy but i just know that you're not
ready yet to have children like you have
so many other plans going on right now
we're also forgetting that you do need a
guide
for the store yeah you definitely need
that yeah that's part of it i'm gonna go
through my exes and see which one mom's
gonna approve of the most
we all know we all know we all know all
right moving on uh
favorite dish or food to cook you better
say
the honest answer i wrote this one down
for everything okay a favorite dish
would be i love pink sauce pasta no the
one that you no no no
no no don't say beyonce because that is
rude that's the correct answer my mom
always says i love to cook
cooking a frozen digiorno pizza does not
count as cooking jennifer
yes it does no it doesn't i have to heat
it up i have to turn on the oven i have
to wash the pan that's cooking for me
mom's like i made dinner last night it's
digiornos it's
a frozen french fries and market
pre-made meatballs
no and and rotisserie chicken that
someone's already oh yeah i've already
waited by the way
and i get the i boil pasta and i put
tomato sauce in there
and most i don't know why you're such a
bad cook i'm not gonna lie
i'm actually not a bad cook i actually
cooked my whole life
mom quesadillas don't count as a dinner
well just because anyone can cook
doesn't mean they can make food too well
actually i'm a better baker okay let's
just
that's not that's not speaking you are a
good baker i'm a good baker i think
sistine's gone better the problem is
your dad never
when i met your dad he didn't really
like
food that much i know that sounds weird
he just cared about like tuna salad
chickens
like all this stuff that really didn't
need to be cooked and so i knew how to
make him his oatmeal and his eggs and
everything
and so i never really learned cook
because he didn't really care he didn't
care if
he ate something yeah like if i if i
make him eggs
and he lets them sit there for two hours
and they're frozen and frozen cold
and then he'll eat them after that so
for me it's like why bother
cooking when you don't care somebody
that doesn't like to eat or care about
food he likes eating but not
he doesn't really one of the most
frustrating things about dad
is that we will make him a big breakfast
or cook him a nice dinner and he'll come
30 minutes later and just be and like it
when it's cold and i said that's not how
we made it
and he likes leftovers cold he doesn't
want me to heat him up so it's not
really
fun to cook for him so for the last 30
years i'm like why bother if he doesn't
really care you just made three little
chefs so doesn't matter that's right
you guys like to cook so that's good
yeah so this person asked what is your
biggest regret
and obviously that's a heavy question it
could be something silly
it could be something very serious god i
don't really i know because i don't i
mean
like i feel like you have a lot of
regrets you don't seem like a pr
like me i mean regret i wish that
i don't know i wish maybe that i uh
you stood up for yourself yeah i stood
up for myself i was a bit stronger as a
like a teenager i didn't i did i i was
so bullied when i was pushed that bully
back i wish i pushed the bully back
because you know what
bullies respond to people who push back
it's true and
they actually leave you alone so but i
would always like cower
you know i was and right into that for a
second because i i know you've had this
experience
i think we all have where we're getting
yelled at by a
friend or or some stranger right and you
let them constantly walk all over you
but i swear the second you stand up to
them
and yell at them back they become your
best friend right or they although
they respect they respect you it's so
strange it is really strange and so i
wish that i had that
i wish that i would i wish i would have
had more strength to
push back on the people that weren't
nice to me you do now though i remember
one story you told me when i was growing
up that there was this one friend of
yours that was just
rude all the time and then one day you
stopped and you're like
you called her out i screamed at her and
i would never scream at any of my
girlfriends and i yelled at her
and it was like she actually started
smiling after it she was like
sick she's like wow she goes i know
you're yeah
you're you're you're actually stronger
than i thought and she was like
actually impressed with manipulative and
we've had a great relationship ever
since this next question
might be my favorite the police ring
saying we've just arrested your daughter
which daughter do you assume they have
oh yeah first and foremost starlight was
the first one that came into my brain
i don't know why okay what do you think
we'd get arrested for
um i would say sophia
um walking down the street falling down
how do you get arrested for
falling down disorderly conduct i would
say sophia accidentally walks out of
trader joe's with something that she
didn't pay for
but on accident like you guys are
missing the main one
i think i would get arrested for a hit
and run or something oh gosh that's
horrible that's horrible
no i would because of a car i'm a
horrible driver right i was going to say
for stalking
stalking oh
no she wouldn't trespass i would
i would just say you would um sneak in
somewhere where you're not supposed to
sneak into your passing
yeah that is stressful oh god you guys
yeah mom not trespassing but sneaking
into a place that you're not allowed to
be in
let her finish her thoughts where am i
sneaking because you
always don't go through the front door
you always think there's an easier
like solution you're a little sneaky
that way like you always think that no
one you're invisible
and you can like and just be invisible
and go around like a crowd or go through
the back door
you're always looking for no it never
works and we always get caught but like
you always think there's another way
i feel like because one day there will
be another way and i'll say i told you
i feel like also the person that would
get arrested for being in a group of
people doing something that they're not
supposed to be doing because it's like
for the night for stories later on like
cool i don't know if it would be stupid
in that crowd yeah should be in that
crowd that they arrested the entire yeah
i didn't think of it
yeah exactly it wasn't my idea i'm the
designated driver
i feel like scarlett would steal no
no i think scarlett would get arrested
for
maybe maybe staying out past curfew
or yeah something like that wait i
thought we're going to the extreme
that's why i said hidden right
yeah you were just like i was like god
wait
that's horrible person died like it
could have been just like a clip
oh i got it scarlets would probably be
for maybe like showing up at an ex's
house and like
stalking burning his clothes exactly oh
my gosh guys
lighting a fire exactly exactly
guaranteeing songs like good for you
okay the next one is what was the worst
date you've ever had
sausage oh my god there was a couple
um i had this date but it wasn't really
a date it was with this photographer and
i didn't know it was a date
and he wanted to go out with me
afterwards
after the shoot and and he was driving
me back to my house
and he was like okay we're going to go
out and i'm like well no we're not i'm
here to take me home
and he was getting so mad that he pulled
over
on the freeway in the emergency lane and
stop the car
and he's like i'm not going anywhere
until you tell me you'll go out with me
what yeah and i got so scared but i'm
like i can't get out of the car
because i'm on a freeway and everyone's
going 65 miles an hour whipping by us
and i'm like if you go get out of the
front seat i was so upset i was like get
out of the friends
i was gonna drive i'm like i'm driving
your car like i was
so scared i was uh no finally i started
screaming at him and he finally listened
to me and he just got back but i
it was like this is the day before like
uber's in a waited call there's no cell
phones
oh so you have been stuck i was stuck in
the emergency lane
in on a freeway how old were you i have
probably like 18.
oh my god yeah it was terrifying it was
really terrifying because he
had like some really bad like mental
illness just take
no for an answer guys i know no means
that was it that was pretty scary for me
no i mean
because i was like oh my god is he going
to pull out in traffic and kill us
it's interesting that a lot of instances
like this happen
to females at a very young age like 18
years old and we really have to
learn unfortunately at a very young age
to sort of defend our put ourselves in a
position
and exactly not put ourselves in and but
that's not true though because sometimes
like i had no idea
he was going to turn like no of course
always of you just trusting that the
person was going to take you right
because of stories like this you have to
always consider the worst case scenario
instead of just thinking it's a harmless
photographer photo shoot driving me in a
car so
that sucks i'm sorry to deal with that
thank you um
what is the best career advice you've
ever received because you're a boss lady
this person said you know it's it's
there's no like easy answer to that one
like there's no like okay just do this
yeah um everyone that i know that's
successful
works really hard i there is no free
passes there's no free rides
if you want to succeed you have to work
hard you have to work harder than
everyone
else you have to you have to show up
early and stay late
i know that sounds really that's why you
tell me and i always tell people
always and be on time yeah you know one
of the worst things you can be
is not on time it means you don't care
about someone else's time sure and
um if if people that have worked for me
and that i have worked for
i'm always on time or ahead and i always
stay late making sure that they need
anything extra and i'm telling you early
bird
and late bird gets the worm and you will
be successful in whatever you do
love that yeah that advice i love this
question
straight to the point because you're all
about skincare and
health and beauty and what do you do for
self-care that always
keeps you glowing but i also think it's
a good question what do you do in your
early 20s that is important that will
help you now
in your 50s that is better later on that
you've seen i think
that's our skin i think personally that
because i know this is going to be like
oh how boring you are
um i never got into like drugs or
smoking to you know i never did any of
that stuff so i think that
that really played like it helped my
skin
i mean you know obviously the same thing
using good skin care and like take
wearing spf and all that other stuff
helps but just like caring for yourself
and not caring for your body and not
like destroying it early on
right because things that you do in your
age like in your teens and twenties
is gonna like really come out in your
50s and 60s so
except you should tell the listeners
what you used to do as your tanning
techniques
when you were our age oh my god you took
her to the worst level
first of all i was a valley girl so we i
would go to the beach and i also worked
at
um bee dyke bathing suits yup her name
was b
dyke and i love it and i worked at a
bikini shop and next door was val surf
so all of us beach girls would get cute
bathing suits from the shop
and then we'd meet everybody in malibu
and we'd go body surfing
roller skating a roller skating and i'd
put baby oil all over my body
and i dropped yourself but at night you
don't know where i worked at night
cysteine oh at night i worked at valley
tan
so if there wasn't anyone coming in i'd
lock the door
i'd hop in the tanning bed for another
20 minutes
to half hour so good so that i'd bake
even in there so i'd bake all day at the
beach and then
bake all day in the tanning bed i think
i think the biggest thing that you've
taught me about skincare is the spf
like speaking of tanning and stuff
because when i was younger
this woman made us look like casper at
the friendly face
dump it and i hated hated i knew what i
did to my skin i see all this age spots
everything popping up now and now i see
some things happening to my face i'm
like
oh sorry aren't you oh yeah now i'm all
about it and i'm like i gotta start now
oh yeah that's a big thing too take care
of yourself when you're young you have a
lot of young listeners
just try not to be easier so have fun
but not like
sun but not too much everything's in
moderation so no drugs and no sun
yeah and yeah you know i wasn't like
totally perfect but
you know i wasn't consistent i think
like occasionally bad is okay totally
occasional
everyone has their advice yeah um this
wasn't specifically a listener question
but a lot of people
asked to hear this story and i think
it'd be really fun if you shared it on
the podcast today because
i don't think anyone actually knows the
real
way that you and dad met like how oh
yeah this is me
okay so we actually met through a mutual
friend he was a manager and i wasn't
signed with him but i had done
some sort of uh shoot with him or
something like that that
i don't really remember i think his name
was michael and um shout out michael
yeah there we go and uh so we he called
me
aft like a few days later after our
shoot he's like hey
um i'm gonna i'm going with a friend of
mine sylvester stallone to dinner
and do you want to come with us do you
want to meet us there
i'm like oh sure i'll meet you there so
here's the funny thing i'm this
girl from the valley i'm living with my
mom i'm 19 years old
and i'm like well i can't meet sylvester
stallone alone you know i got to bring
one of my valley girlfriends with me
so my friend kirsten gets in my car and
now at the time i'm driving a dodge
duster
you guys i don't think they don't make
dodge dusters anymore and this car
was a piece of junk my bro oh i
shouldn't say it my brother gave it to
me
i put it this way i sold it for 250 so
can you imagine how nice this car
it was a steal it had rusted keys
nothing worked on it like
i couldn't everything was at zero and
empty so none of the
monitors worked on the car so i never
knew a house car you know
i didn't have a gas cap i actually stuck
a rag in there because i
someone stole my gas cap at school
someone took off all the trim off the
car because they're like your car's a
piece of [ __ ] and ripped
part of the trim was coming off so they
re-ripped it all the way off yeah
and it had a sticker on it said another
shitty day in paradise
oh my god so so i would drive down the
street and i had to get gas every few
days because i never knew if i had gas
in my car so that was pretty bad like i
was like am i on empty am i on full
who knows just put 10 bucks in the car
and it'll keep going anyway
and it and it took about probably 45
minutes in the morning to
to warm up so i would have to jump out
of bed turn on the car
go back to bed take a shower brush my
teeth eat breakfast and then come out to
the car and
finally it would have been a lot of
water this dodge
this dodge duster to me and it had like
i had this like yeah so i took the dodge
duster to meet slide so we go to this
restaurant right
and die trust me i show up and i'm
looking good my dodge
and they show up and what are you
wearing and then this okay i had like my
sisters and i have two sisters and we
didn't have a lot of money so we shared
all of our clothes so we shared
underwear to everything we just shared
everything
and so we always our date suit we had
this one like little white jacket
like very like form-fitting little white
jacket a little white skirt i wore
white pumps and blue eyeshadows i love
it and this is the 80s this is the late
80s so we always teased our hair and it
was super blonde and i like
super tan so i look like kind of a
little bit of a rocker girl
and a super tan of course because of
valley and just so i
uh we show up my friend kirsten and i
and he's with so i was sitting at the
table and i guess this guy michael
invited all these other girls
so it was you know it was like so many
other women and he decides like i don't
you know is this a club this is a
restaurant it was a restaurant it's
closed down now so you walk in
and you see dad and that guy michael
with like
six girls on each side yeah it was like
a but it didn't matter to me because it
wasn't a date or anything
you know it's kind of like my first time
in hollywood i've never been down to
hollywood before like the movie valley
girl
yeah except you're nicholas cage
and so no i'm not nicholas cage was from
home
that's right no you're not maybe someone
cuter like
what was it jennifer jason lee wasn't
she in this yeah i think yeah yeah
so no she was from was she from valley
she always saw fast times
hi honey i'm doing the podcast with
you're on you're on the air
you are on i'm telling about our dates i
the first time you met mom
i remember honey it was the best date
ever
yeah i was telling how i showed up in a
dodge duster
no i wasn't i was in that cute white
suit remember no
you were a curtain that you stole from
the hotel that's right
but no with my friend kirsten and uh
anyways
i was saying how i showed up and then
you said come in the limo and i was like
no
i'm gonna where and you said we're going
to a club and i said okay but i can't go
with you because stranger danger go mom
so
all the other girls hopped in the car
with you and i
followed in my dodge duster to a club
downtown there we go
no i was like i was like fred flintstone
and i ran i didn't have like i just my
girlfriend
no engine there's no engine i'm partying
right now
exactly i
i thought my god this girl is incredible
that
she is actually so sweet considering
she has a dodge duster oh what does that
mean
hey i had wheels
what made mom out of all the girls that
were sitting at that table the one that
stuck out to you the most
uh she was like a deer in the headlights
she was like a little elf that was
facing king kong
she was so vulnerable and sweet and
completely out of her element she just
seemed so
fresh where everyone around me was like
a gangster a killer
like everyone was jaded from hollywood
yeah they were really tough girls they
asked me what i did
and i go um i go to college and i work
at valley tan
and the whole table started laughing at
me oh and i was like
and my girlfriend looks at me she goes
what's wrong with working at valley tan
i go i have no idea
[Laughter]
in the valley for 19 years and had never
ventured over the hill to hollywood in
i went to 50 states i went on
in a camper across the country so i just
because i haven't been to
i went to every state in the united
states and every national monument i
went to every
from the black hills to florida well no
you're just reinforcing my point
the fact that you can go to north dakota
but you can't go
to hollywood to hollywood yeah curiosity
valley's a very big place we have no
reason to come back hollywood
valley's huge we have malibu we'd go
over you know canaan
or malibu canyon and we didn't need
hollywood sorry
you know we ask you one question you
give us the strangest answer okay i love
you honey um i'll be home in about
fifteen
okay we need to finish your version of
the story so my version is you go to the
club we go to the club i follow him with
all the girls in the limousine
and i'm following with my girlfriend and
we get to the club
and he's talking this one girl is
talking to him
constantly and i think oh that must be
his girlfriend so um
i follow her to the bathroom and sly
starts talking to me a lot and i felt
uncomfortable because she's giving me
dirty looks and i'm thinking oh no maybe
they're in a relationship
right so i follow her to the bathroom
and i'm just gonna i just ask her i go
are you guys seeing each other
because if you are i'm i'm out of here
it's fine you know i don't care i don't
know this guy
i go i'll leave and she goes good idea
so
wow so i went to the table got my person
i didn't even say goodbye to him i just
was walking listen to her yeah i would
have too
i didn't i didn't well first of all i'm
not i don't feel like getting in the
middle of someone's relationship
yeah so for me i just was like okay i'm
out of here
like i'm not gonna i don't know these
people whatever and
i was leaving and he came after me and i
said well i don't want to break up
anything between you and your girlfriend
he goes i just met her tonight
so i was like ooh she's a naughty
naughty girl so then we ended up getting
a table by ourselves
oh yeah and the rest is history yeah
her story i love that that was our first
day so romantic i love a lot of
um but our first real single first date
was horseback riding
oh that's cute because we both like a
guy to see me in a crowd and go
her her by the way did we not talk about
that on the last podcast
we're in a sea of people we lock eyes
with someone well you were
this was in loop with toxic girl summer
now this is like healthy girl summers
we're at a club or we're at a bar or a
restaurant i like healthy girls summer
i know you do but we also want a little
bit of a i think you've all had enough
of them
you know maybe mom's right maybe we
should go back to healthy girls
somewhere maybe we'll actually find a
boyfriend if we stop staying toxic
i think that you manifest what you want
so you guys are not manifest
toxic you're going to get toxic i think
i should just date the ghost in our
house
he's always there for me i thought you
said it was late i thought you said
there's two there's two oh speaking of
i'd like to bring this up my mom is
completely against
all things ghosts conspiracies she never
believes me even though there was that
one time
you heard the door slam 2 and you and i
walked around the entire house with
weapons because we thought there was an
intruder
yes there's about to be a ghost it
turned out that there was
it was windy outside and there's some
air draft in the house
the door came it was the fisherman ghost
you know it
and you don't believe in that stuff but
i also don't want you guys to be afraid
by the way has the ghost
ever hurt any of you she just said she
doesn't want it to be us to be afraid
she does believe in it yeah just own it
i just want one story i walk around the
house
with it pitch black and nothing has like
slipped my throat
or tripped me or like went boo yeah
because they can't hurt you
so but you have a story of when you
lived in a certain house and you said it
was for sure haunted
and i don't know how you couldn't
believe it well this was like this
happened to you
bill whorehouse this was like seriously
so seriously like people saw demons in
the staircase
seriously why would you this is house i
didn't buy it your dad was renting it
and then he bought it and then get
sold it back to the guy who he bought it
from and then the house eventually
burned to the ground wait
okay did you sell it back because you
were afraid of
the spirit i just think that a lot of
weird things kept going on in this house
so how can you deny it
um yeah that house burnt to the ground
it burnt to the ground it was not when
we owned it but when someone else owned
it
yeah name is something that happened
that was paranormal okay so what like
okay so
a crazy thing is first of all the house
was filled with
rats in the attic so all night long we'd
hear rats not that those are good that's
just dirty that's just gross
um uh one time
i we were we closed the bathroom doors
there was two bathroom doors we closed
them both and
we woke up in the morning there were
thousands
of dead flies no windows were open
nothing was opened
thousands of dead flies everywhere in
the bathroom
then another time a family member was uh
at night and they're in the back
staircase and they said they
saw demons every time all right okay
i just looked and my sister said she
constantly heard
rattling of windows and like the alarm
would go off in the house when she was
staying there
i think the most nuts thing out of
everything is by the end of this whole
thing
all these paranormal experiences the
house itself and no one knew
how it happened no burnt to the ground
it burnt to the ground okay that was
like a hell house yeah literally you
open the door to thousands of
dead flies it symbolizes that the devil
is watching and evil is upon you no it
was i'm telling you so you were hanging
out
at the devil's house i know i know this
house was truly scary house how do we
know she's not possessed
who me yeah you bro she brought the
ghosts from no i did not know yes
totally different ghosts by the way it's
totally different not different because
ghosts are brought in through things so
it's it's not they don't just wake up in
someone's house or wander in
say if you bring in an antique
cup right right it came with the cup
who knows what you carried in from that
house well i think your dad is the one
that carries in a lot he definitely
takes stuff
but we do have like sculptures and stuff
that are quite old
paintings that are old so maybe
something and something who knows but
you know what
all i can say is the house we are in now
a friendly ghost if there's a ghost
because i mean they're not okay they're
actually like that there's no like they
keep it interesting yeah how do you feel
if we
saged the house or brought in a a medium
i don't mind that i think it's kind of
fun
wow i'm actually very surprised by that
yeah because i don't think there's no
harm
to it i think that if you feel it and
you think it i think if you think it's
going to help then
we're going to do it we got it on video
we got it on audio you're agreeing to it
we're going to follow up next week mom
thank you so much for coming on the show
today
we love you and i know the listeners
love having you on and
oh maybe one day we'll just make you
permanent oh my god i would love
that will make sure that i'm always with
you guys oh we love you
okay we'll do it again thank you thank
you guys for joining us on this week's
episode you guys can check us out on
apple podcast spotify
youtube or instagram instagram
all about on wax podcast and go check
out jennifer's instagram she has a lot
of cava foods on it jennifer flavin
jennifer flavin stallone and you can see
photos of us too i think her
instagram is 90 dogs and children
so we love it we love it i love it thank
you guys see you next week
bye from all of us here at the show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts spotify
follow your hosts at sophia stallone and
at sistine stallone
and be sure to follow the show at
unwaxed podcast we'll see you next week